hey Conan O'Brien here this is a very  special day get this 25 years ago today  I made my first late-night show and  since then I've taped over 4,000  episodes 9 of which I'm told are quite  good anyway today in honor of this great  event we are re releasing that first  episode it looks amazing the engineers  even managed to give me the voice of an  adult male very excited about all of  this and this is just a little taste of  what's coming in January beginning of  the year we are going to be debuting a  state of the art website that has just  about everything I've ever done in  late-night you got a tune in for all the  excitement that's coming your way  because it's gonna be a lot of laughs  what is that